today's question comes from Burton in
Ohio Dave we use our debit card most of
the time but when making a purchase
online we use our credit card I've
always heard that if a criminal attacks
your card it's better if it's a credit
card than a debit card do you agree
absolutely do not agree as a matter of
fact neither does Visa or MasterCard if
you were to go to visas website you can
find very quickly and easily under the
security section that they have a zero
liability policy for fraud or online
theft or identity theft for credit cards
and debit cards simple now if a credit
card gets misused online you don't pay
the bill if a debit card gets misused
online they might take money out of your
checking account that could happen but
the bank is required to put it back
within a matter of just a few business
days
from the time that you report it as
online theft required by Visa it is a
part of visas transaction the debit card
has the exact same fraud protection as
the credit card the exact same I buy
stuff online all the time sometimes I
buy large things on line with my debit
card and I don't blink now here's the
thing the only downside is you might be
out of the cash for a few days that's
the difference with a credit card you
haven't ever paid the bill yet and so
you've got the debt on there until they
clear the transaction off for being a
fraudulent transaction in the case of
the debit card the money might you might
50 bucks might come out of your account
it might be several days before you get
that fifty bucks back but it's not long
it's not it's not two years it's not six
months it's not even a month it's a
matter of a few business days they're
required to put it back I'm racking my
brain trying over if it's five or seven
or three it's one of those three numbers
but I can't remember but anyway that's
not as part of the liability policy
that's just a banking
requirement so visa gives the you can
look it up it's right there on their
site there's so everybody running around
it's amazing these consumer guys
remember the debit card is not safe it's
a credit card we yes it is the same
stinking coverage exactly it's a zero
liability policy now again you might be
out the cash for a little bit with a
debit card
don't use your debit card sometimes
you're out cash for other things like
you check into a hotel they may put a
hold on your account for a little while
you rent a car they may put a hold on
your account for a little while that's
part of it so part of using a debit card
is you actually have to have money
that's the thing and the point is is
that if you quit use the stupid credit
cards you will have money by getting in
control and quit spending money you
don't have to buy things you don't need
to impress people you don't really like
so its rationalization and justification
that people use all the time just like
to stupid travel points and and it just
has caused an entire industry to suck
the blood out of the middle-class then
the industry is the credit card industry
so same exact fraud protections hope it
wasn't unclear